from one to ten only six and a half on
the high Richter scale I will give
myself a 6 to 7 on the high rated
scalability of being stoned I like to
pride myself on being a functional
stoner people don't suspect the guy in
the tie to be completely blazed I'll
probably get a world record when I was a
kid I actually beat pop it
I think heads you like a hundred 115
around I just practiced um I think I
bought it for some reason I'm making a
beat like a recluse
my name is boy bricks and I got my own
toy I'm playing with it looking that
insane oh boy yup yup what is it what
are the loops and pull how would you
know what a sound looks like you can't
read sounds oh I hate it I hate you Bop
It this is a great game bother you you
could play this while you're waiting for
a stew to finish I think first thing in
the morning probably the best time to
play this game so you're waking up your
mind and you're waking up your hand bop
is a toy made so why people won't kill
other people the Bob that sounds good
they got recorded when Bugs Bunny would
fall down stairs and then why the
creator of Bop it was like that's a good
idea to play to their children's game a
person shrieking after it be I don't
know stab a man had 3 / 3 pet frogs and
he caught him and he spent a only
different sounds and when they died he
put his ashes
this machine you're hearing dead frogs
it's a tragedy
it's a recipe but who I am is Britt you
see we're gonna hit these box do the
bottles matter faculty school get this
camp